your first short film was in 1994 yeah
it was called no to monarchy and I
collaborate on that was Avery Williams
and it was more like a mini feature it
was more like I mean we were like
because you know I say that because
Avery loved him dearly he's in Atlanta
right now and he's teaching at Morehouse
but he wrote that script and he brought
it to me to direct and I was like well
you know we're gonna do this to the
school and we sort of did it in school
but we sort of didn't do the school we
kind of broke all the rules right we
used the school's equipment but we ended
up we so we started the film process
there but then because of my earlier
work I had gotten the attention of
Disney Hollywood Pictures and they
started this discretionary fund program
and so they decided to give us $40,000
to make that movie it was a period films
period film set in Harlem 1947 and we
had Keith David in and we had harry
lennix and it you know both big actors
right now and so we were just young kids
just I mean just like fresh behind the
ears you know 21 22 you know not really
knowing a whole lot what we're doing
figuring it out as we go but just kept
being it very professional and in that
film went on doing a lot of awards and
get me a lot of attention got both of us
a lot of attention well I'm forty
thousand and ninety-four yes
yeah that's a lot so it's 2019 now and
you are just releasing your first
feature film yeah yeah I think the ad is
about the whole Oh dad is about you know
what's holding you back you it probably
stands true and I think for a lot of
years I resisted writing right I became
a better writer over the years but when
I first started out I didn't really
particularly write as much and I think
that the filmmakers that are really
prolific are the ones that really can
get there faster they generate their own
material right and they write so it goes
hand in hand they write and they
directly right near it
so if you don't write you either have a
define material or work with other
writers right and
I didn't write for a lot of years and so
look at the gap between when I graduated
film school when I came out with my
first feature a lot of it is because I
was learning how to write in that period
of time
yeah learning how to write mm-hmm were
you reading screenplay books I was
reading screenplay books but then life
happens yeah you know and so I came out
here early 2000 high hopes of directing
but I just didn't have him put me right
away
it did happen and I had to get a job and
so then I started looking at what what
are my options and then I'd always done
sound in school I was pretty good at
doing sound as a production sound person
in school so then I started doing sound
out in LA for commercials and videos and
mm-hmm so then what was it that made you
want to do a feature film like what why
were you ready what is it 2 years ago
yeah yeah what time was getting away
from me you know and I figured that was
my dream you know I didn't want to get
away from my dream of being a director
and so I just hang her down and I did
whatever to I just that was my mantra I
just society I'm gonna do whatever it
takes and I'm gonna confront myself at
every corner and so look at my
weaknesses and I'm gonna make my
weaknesses into strengths and so then I
just started to write and write and
write and and then then I hope to put
another collaborator another writer
Steven Pearson Steven Palmer Peterson
and he wrote skin in the game and so
will you almost emulating Spike Lee
getting up at 6 I was lighting up a 6
but early I mean it's like even right
now you know like the cost you know it
takes a lot to be filmmaker and I think
those that make it of it probably is
it's more it's more determination and
persistence versus talent a lot of times
I mean talent hand in hand you know you
you know you take that for granted but
you want to be talented at it but I
think it's it's really about persistence
and determination and how much you're
willing to sacrifice in some cases yeah
because in some cases there it you know
you've got you may not be eating
maybe eating top ramen or you may be
taking some least attractive jobs
because it allows you more time to write
right and I think that's when I made
that decision and you're not leaning on
other people in other words you're the
responsibility for your life and
becoming a filmmaker is yours it doesn't
belong to your wife so your partners do
boyfriends or your mother's or Father's
so it's not about them sponsoring you or
giving you a cushion or saying okay you
know what you go ahead and write here's
I'm gonna pay your rent for the next
couple months so it's it was about
taking complete responsibility for my
dream and what I want to make happen and
what that looked like and so yeah so if
it meant working all day and writing all
night and that's what I did
you